what's up everybody its Warren and we
have some huge Avengers in game leaks
today and with these leaks comes
confirmation for a few things and
Avengers in games so needless to say if
you are trying to avoid any spoilers for
Avengers in game you should click away
now if you're still with me a few months
ago we had a leak come out that showed
Thor and rocket on the back of a toy
packaging on the back of this toy
packaging they were wearing all white
suits and many people believe them to be
quantum realm suits and then not too
long after that we got some leaked
photos of what appeared to be all of the
Avengers who are left in these quantum
realm suits now a lot of people tried to
say that these were fake that they
looked Photoshop and they just weren't
real well as it turns out they are real
and this is confirmed because as it
turns out some Avengers in-game toys
have hit the shelves in some non-us
countries that's right the Avengers
Titan hero series toys are on the
shelves in some non-us countries and
with the release of these toys come some
pretty big reveals and confirmations for
Avengers endgame so to start off we see
some of the Avengers in those all-white
suits with the Avengers logo on them
believed to be the quantum realm suits
I think it's obvious at this point that
the Avengers are going to have to go
inside of the quantum realm for one
reason or another whether that be time
travel or going to an alternate
dimension they're going to have to go
inside of the quantum realm and based on
everything that Hank Pym has told us
about the quantum realm the Avengers
will need some sort of suit to go inside
so for everybody who was saying that
these are fake these suits aren't real
they are real the toys for them have
already come out and we see the Avengers
wearing them and one particular Avenger
that we see wearing these suits is the
Hulk we've seen the Hulk wearing this
suit before and even the first promo
photo for Avengers in game that came out
had the Hulk wearing a suit and now that
we have this toy leaked with him
actually wearing the suit it's confirmed
that he will wear the suit but what does
this mean it most likely means that
Professor Hulk is coming an Avengers
infinity war Banner and the Hulk were
fighting against each other
professor Hulk is basically the ideal
version of
and the Hulk it has the Hulk's body but
banners brain and the fact that the Hulk
is wearing a suit means two things for
Avengers in game one is that he finally
comes out and two is that he's actually
cooperating with banner enough to put on
this suit so a lot more evidence for a
professor Hulk to come out in Avengers
end game and the last part of this leak
is pretty big it confirms a pretty big
character coming back in Avengers in
game and that is Valkyrie as you can see
here she has her own toy which means
that she will indeed be back for
Avengers in game the Russo brothers told
us that in the beginning of Infinity
Ward when Thanos boards Thor's ship half
of the Asgardians actually got away and
aboard that ship was Valkyrie in fact
she was probably the one that helped
them all get away and it appears that
she survived the snap which means that
at some point in Avengers in game she
will meet up with the rest of the
Avengers again and Thor we know that
Stormbreaker has the power to summon the
Bifrost perhaps Thor goes out and looks
for her or maybe she leads the rest of
the remaining as guardians to earth at
the end of Thor Ragnarok Thor did say
that they were going to earth so perhaps
when Valkyrie fled with the rest of the
Asgardians they went to earth and maybe
when they're coming to earth they run
into a little ship called the Benatar
that would have Tony Stark and nebula on
it
perhaps Valkyrie Korg and meek are the
ones that end up saving Tony Stark
however she ends up regrouping with the
Avengers it's clear by this toy leaked
that she's going to be back in Avengers
in game and have a pretty big role if
she's getting her own toy so that's it
for these brand new Avengers and game
toy leaks let me know what you think of
them let me know what you think about
the brand new quantum realm suits
professor Hulk and Valkyrie returning
and Avengers and game let me know your
thoughts in the comments down below and
the new round of the Infinity Gauntlet
giveaway still continues if you would
like to enter for your chance to win a
life-sized Infinity Gauntlet all you
have to do is subscribe to my channel
like this video and comment down below
with your thoughts and your favorite
superhero as always thank you all so
much for watching
woof woof
[Music]
you